welcome to the across the spoiler ver
podcast I'm your homie Paul dressed up
as bedman right now because uh I looked
at the Golden Globes last night and I
thought look it's a very prestigious
event everyone's out there having a good
time they're all dressed in their own
great stuff so I thought I'd I'd come up
rocking my finest wees from Matalan and
H yeah that's why I decided to do the
whole podcast in this which is just
basically a big bed sheet so thanks a
lot guys for all your support and making
it so I can get SP sponsored by Batman
bed sheet H so how are you doing Greg
you look fly I'm doing all right man I'm
doing all right I'm excited to talk
about we got Golden Globes we got a
little bit of Jonathan Majors we got
mainly that I feel like there's
something else there's another main
topic in there well Greg I'm sure I
don't know how it skipped your mind
because it's all I've seen on Twitter
this week which is uh the whole thing
about the ray movie and the director
with that that's what it
is yes yeah so
completely inescapable uh we will be
talking about that as well and but
firstly I just want to kick it off with
the Aquaman or Aquaman box office
because I know if I don't say Aquaman
people uh people in America get really
annoyed at me Greg they're like it's
aqua and I'm like okay mate we just say
different things depending on on where
we live in the world but yeah that's
past $300 million worldwide it's now the
highest grossing dce movie this side of
the pandemic it's outdone Black Adam
it's likely going to break even and come
in around $500 million but I'm kind of
hoping that it it breaks the billion
Greg and it just has Warner Brothers
thinking um maybe we should go back to
that plan and they do 10 more years of
just messing about and getting
everything wrong and just doing complete
reactionary stuff where they don't know
what movie they're making next and it's
just quickly edit it to make it a comedy
and then when the comedy goes downhill
they're like no quick edit the next one
and make it really
dark I can't wait to see how well this
does man this is so bad
I can't get over the DC you failing so
bad it's I mean it's fine it's better it
did better than I think right is that
the conversation now that people are now
happy that it's doing better like oh my
God it's not as egregiously terrible as
we thought this is still not great I
don't care what anyone says this is
still not great yeah I mean when it's
beating the MCU I mean hats off to them
at at DC Studios they finally got their
wish and they they beat Marvel at
something so congratulations guys um
quick correction from last time we need
to printer atraction Greg I'm a bit
annoyed but you might remember last week
on the podcast we kept slagging off sky
dance when we were talking about scream
just kept going Sky Dancer absolutely
[__] H but yeah it turns out was spy
glass so I don't ever think that Tom
Cruz is going to be uh coming on the
podcast anytime soon Greg because that's
his company obviously and we we spent
the last 20 minutes of last week's
podcast getting everything wrong but
that's why we're the premier number one
podcast on movies on a Tuesday evening
released at 8:00 P.M on a specific time
because that's that that's how we do
Greg but but did it create engagement in
the comments did it create did people
common
policers yeah they did but you know what
I a lot of people think that's good
engagement that people are constantly
correcting you but I'm just always kind
of embarrassed by it and I personally
don't think it's good engagement because
people are like these guys are idiots
and don't know what they're talking
about but at least we kind of admitted
Greg now someone who hasn't really
admitted to much things is Jonathan
major uh earlier in the week well not it
was kind of towards the end of last week
start of this week um Coleman Domingo he
was rumored as being recast as Kang in
the MCU I think that's great um casting
I think he's a brilliant actor be The
Walking Dead fantastic in Euphoria he
there was yeah during the pandemic there
was an episode where they had to really
pull back the cast and just have two
character characters basically for the
whole episode and that was Zen and
Coleman's character and they just sat in
a diner blew my mind that whole episode
that was fantastic um
and yeah yeah exactly um and I think he
would be great in the role I mean
everything about the guy he just ooes
Charisma he's got a sort of I don't know
that it feels like there's some he's
very intelligent the way he comes across
um but he doesn't often say that much
but you can see him working away
mentally in a just kind of creates a a
character that I feel would be perfect
for a villain where it's kind of like
you can tell there's a lot going on
beneath the surface and he's just
bringing it to the Forefront now
Jonathan mes commanding voice though I
want to throw that in there his his
voice just that bravado in there the
baritone I mean bravado baritone yeah
he's got a sort of raspiness to it that
really kind of yeah he he does a lot
with it and he's a fantastic actor and I
think a lot of people when they he this
news you know Denzel gets thrown out
there a lot there's a lot of actors that
often get brought up but this was the
first one that I really heard where I
was like okay this would be a big big
thing for the franchise I think you know
Denzel would be be great in the role um
but I think we'd know it was Denzel you
know what I mean because he's such a big
star where I think I think Coleman could
completely fit into that role but
perhaps you know maybe there's not going
to be a recast as yeah Jonathan Maes has
come out and done this interview with
Good Morning America as of recording
this um that Greg um the cynical side of
me says that Disney are just completely
milking this whole thing because
apparently what they're doing is they're
releasing it in four segments and then
they're releasing a fifth exclusive
segment on Hulu that is kind of a an end
end sort of conversation thing um and I
just find are youing a joke that's real
I I did not know any of that they're
really doing it that way yeah so they've
split it up um they're releasing it like
that and yeah it's kind of wild because
yeah Disney obviously owned Good Morning
America so basically what Disney have
done is they fired him and then gotten
back on to do the tell all interview
about the firing it brings a whole new
meaning to the phrase exit interview
personally I'm not sure of the Optics of
firing someone because they harm your
company's reputation and but then
bringing them on and giving them a
platform to be like well we we had to
get let go of you because you were
causing too much controversy for us but
uh here's a tell interview in which uh
yeah you're going to get a chance of
speaking stuff so obviously there's been
a lot of um stuff on the internet about
it I again I personally think if you're
gonna cut ties with someone then cut
ties with them don't cut ties and then
try make money off their downfall and
release it in four segments with an
exclusive end part on Hulu but what are
your thoughts on it Greg i'm Blown Away
by what you just told me I had no idea
about that that they were really cuz I I
knew we were going to talk about it a
little bit today to double check it Greg
cuz I don't want to be printing another
retraction do the create engagement is
there is there a comments uh I'm I'm
okay with with that uh but I from
another
YouTuber that is insane to me if they
are doing that they was before you know
I I don't exactly know what uh the
conversation was about doing the Good
Morning America thing I thought it was a
little like ridiculous because it did
feel like the way they were advertising
it did feel like something the boys with
parody and I did see you know the at the
time of recording this uh there were two
parts that were on the Good Morning
America YouTube channel so I I watched
those uh beforehand and I've
intentionally avoided uh the whatever
you know Twitter is saying because I
just I haven't looked at anything of
what people's responses have been to it
it's a fascinating interview to me
because I think he's trying to obviously
do like damage control he feels like he
needs to talk about things and it seems
like the interviews the kind of if you
believe he's he shouldn't have been
found guilty you're going to probably
really like this interview if you feel
like no he deserved to be found guilty
then you're going to have a completely
different type of opinion on this
interview right like just the way it it
goes especially what he's doing here
because it doesn't take at the end of
the day it's it's one of those things
where
in my opinion like again this is my
opinion I'm no expert here I'm just
going off of what the interview itself
was doing that I felt there there could
have been some level of accountability
like they even acknowledge in there that
he wasn't found guilty of intention of
like intending to harm her at all right
and and I think that's something that
I'm glad they really emphasized that
because when Jonathan major was first
arrested
the instant image that was put out was
like oh my God is this guy like a
domestic terrorist is is he like a
violent abuser like all the things that
I don't think that's a domestic
terrorist did they Greg no I don't think
that was the world I'm saying the
domestic abuser did I say
domestic you said domestic terrorist I'm
like instant demonetization right there
uh maybe we mute it to have people think
what I said and then we create
engagement and will go what did Greg
actually type uh that's the goal here
just to create engagement off of wrong
things stated today the but anyway my my
point is that people thought like he was
probably this like violent inre just guy
and what he was found guilty of like
they stated in there that you know it
was something along the lines of he
didn't intend it was it was an accident
essentially it was like Reckless
Behavior but he it wasn't an intention
of harm and I think there could and I I
think a lot of us are understanding
enough to to the Point even for those
who like on my end I'm hearing I'm going
yeah I mean I see I've seen it happen so
many times with toic couples doesn't
make it okay you know it's sometimes an
accident might happen in in a situation
but that doesn't mean they intended to
harm the person and I I I think he
didn't take there was one part in the
interview where where she did question
him like how'd she get this um they
showed the photos how'd she get this
injury and he just pauses for a long
time he's like I wish I knew or I don't
know and it was in that point where I
feel like it kind of could have done him
a little bit of Goodwill if he just
admitted I I it was an accident occurred
you know but it wasn't intentional there
was a moment where he gets sort of
almost put towards saying sorry but what
he says is I just shouldn't have been in
the car I shouldn't have been in the
relationship rather than saying I should
be sorry for for doing that and mean I
mean look the verdict is what it is um
we've kind of not weighed that much on
it
I personally always think these
interviews no matter what are always
pretty much a bad luck and there's a
number of instances where this has
happened um I remember you know Alec
Baldwin did one after the shooting on
Rust H Jesse Smet did one Prince
Andrew's done one Amber herd did one or
Kelly did one and I think I personally
believe that a lot of you know actors
and celebrities are known for being
egotistical and Vain and I think a lot
of the time these interviews are sort of
made with that in mind where it's kind
of how will I look in an interview this
is a chance for me to save my reputation
and come back and I think they make the
wrong choice in going this route um
because it can often you know that that
narcissism almost can kind of jump off
the screen and I I do feel some of the
things that Mages said did slip a bit
towards making him sound narcissistic
almost um I think he's a fantastic actor
I'm I'm not when I heard the verdict I
was like okay I that doesn't actually
sound bad when you completely break it
down it sounds more accidental from what
they've said um it wasn't intentional
assault it was caused by him it was
something along those lines where it
wasn't necessarily um assault carried
out with intention to harm or something
along those lines but when he when he's
bringing up you know again bringing up
Martin Luther King and the Civil Rights
and stuff and it just kind of takes it
down the direction that developed in the
trial when we heard the voice recordings
and how he was saying he was a great man
and he wanted his girlfriend and partner
to be like someone like Michelle Obama
or something and it's kind of like look
you need to pull back from the situation
and realize you're just a person you've
been given these opportunities in life
you've messed them up but it doesn't
make you this great man just because
you're an actor and this is kind of this
interview didn't paint him out in the
best light I don't think and a lot of
people have been saying it's like the
boys and there's so many different
levels to that because V in that is
obviously a corporation that can you
know what I mean
Spin The Narrative a certain way they
control all their talent which you could
see Disney being akin to I mean if you
look at corporations Disney are pretty
much Evol at this point and to have them
basically doing a deep interview um on
it was it's very surreal um especially
the trailer that was kind of weird and
it just kind of feels like they've
misjudged the situation on this now I
was thinking when that trailer released
I was thinking well this trailer is
really corny and kind of comes across
90s but Disney and Good Morning America
can they can control the edit so they
can very much control the narrative but
even seeing it edited it didn't come
across that well I don't think and there
wasn't anything that I think if you
looked at the trial there wasn't
anything that you gained from this and
honestly I mean coming out of the trial
I was actually not I wasn't like rooted
on major's side but I did have sympathy
for him and think oh look by the sounds
of it this has been you know he hasn't
intentionally done this thing he's ran
away from um the person who was accusing
him he's clearly tried to get out the
situation but then seeing you know the
the messages the recordings and then
this on top of it it's kind of like ah
it's difficult to to Really you know
what I mean go on that side and I think
what we heard in the the aftermath of
the trial was that the jury weighed in a
lot on the more existential information
um rather than necessarily what happened
on the night and even when he's getting
question like did you he got something
like did you break her heart he said
something like not I broke her heart but
not her body or something it was along
those lines and it's just kind of it's
very surreal seeing these sort of things
it was question about harmed her
physically and he talked about how like
heart hurt her heart and yeah which is
focus on the emotional abusive side of
the
relationship and um you know the the
power that he demonstrated there which
yeah I mean it it shows it it's again
it's a it's a lack of accountability you
know saying I broke her heart it's not
really like you know I mean me and you
could say we broke some girls Hearts you
know what I mean Greg it doesn't
necessarily paint us out as being hor
horrendous horrible people it might just
some I'm sure I've broke a lot of
listeners Hearts when I come out with my
dumb opinions but um you know what I
mean it's less it's completely it's
saying that you hurt someone physically
is like a completely another level
especially when it's a partner and
trying to kind of not even taking
accountability for it saying like oh you
know it was an
accident happened I should have yeah
that's all you need to say just show
some accountability towards it um and
don't kind of try and Dodge everything I
I think to sorry just to interject is
that I I think like to summarize what
you're saying of what I like doing these
interviews especially when you do them
the timing of when you do them it it
we're at a point now where where we
understand media like most of us where
we it just reads to some degree of
insincere there's some part of us that
reads this as like there's there's a I
feel like I'm watching some PR thing I
don't I don't really feel like I'm
watching an interview that is truly
stemming from the heart in some way you
know like even like the wiping of the
tear and stuff like that and and
especially when you're an actor you're
even more likely to be question on how
sincere is this [__] because you're
known to be performative you're known to
channel emotions known to put up an act
and I I think that yeah the the idea of
doing this like right away like I think
this might have been more effective and
and felt more real if it was like a more
of a sitdown thing like months later or
some [__] but not like not now um it
just feels like Panic induced and and a
big I feel like I'm watching a PR thing
you could feel the notes of like don't
admit to this don't say this you could
just feel all that and it's a so you get
the [__] pickup and that that will
outshine anything that is sincere
yeah I think just the setting in general
as well it's it is very stag you you
know the lighting's at a certain point
so it looks kind of it looks more like a
closed set when there's probably a lot
of people standing around them the way
they're kind of put in chairs and stuff
that does take away sort of the the
naturalistic side of it um and it just
it does paint a sort of awkwardness
because it's rare that you actually sit
down like that and speak with someone
and I think you're I think you're
completely right about it sounding like
a PR thing
Disney didn't really well I I got told
off for saying that Good Morning America
are like a totally different thing to
Disney even though Disney own them no I
I do think Disney have final say over
this stuff and just looking at how it's
split up Greg um I have got the
information on it so Good Morning
America will be airing clips of it and
then ABC will be airing the extended
interview on Prime with Lindsey Davis um
at 7M ET
that's cross Network it's not it is
clearly controlled by Disney it's
clearly controlled by Disney so all the
people who who when I put out my first
thoughts on it they were like no but
they're different sides well Disney's
clearly got the hand in it because
they're they're doing it across Network
um oh that
is I had no idea about any of that oh
that so ugly and I think if it wasn't on
Disney well good morning America again
but they were clearly throwing softball
question at him there wasn't really
anything getting into the nitty grits of
it
like even throwing a question like well
if someone did this to your girlfriend
or your mother what do you think should
happen to them do you think they should
still work again you know what I mean
and that kind of catches them in the
situation where they they have to talk
about what they would how they would
view it happening to someone else and
that's that's often when you get the
more honest um things it's often
something judges do in Trials when
someone's protesting their their
innocence and they say well you say you
haven't committed this murder but if
someone had committed it what sentence
would you give them and then the judge
kind of throws a curveball at them and
if they go life in prison that's like
well we think you did it so you get life
in prison mate congratulations you
decided it yourself um so yeah just felt
like a weird PR move and yeah I just I
don't know why he did this I mean again
nothing really came out that we didn't
already know and I think in general it
just kind of paints him out in a
negative light because people are
dunking on him now and doing memes about
it and making him kind of the butt of
the joke and you can guarantee that SNL
right now they're probably SAT writing
the most mid script for a skit that
you've ever seen Greg they're literally
typing away right now trying to get
something together for Saturday night
probably had he probably had more
passionate Defenders before this like he
he did have a there there was a big
passionate defense base around this even
for those acknowledging like what he was
found guilty of there's there at the end
of the day it is that there you can have
multiple opinions on this I I think so a
lot time dealing with the internet so of
course you're going to be dealing with a
lot of like just black and white
opinions all the time and we have the
opportunity to discuss whereas usually
you're dealing with like a comment box
thread or someone's quick senten
whatever and I I think that the one of
the craziest parts to me is like at the
end of the day one thing in the trial
that that did show for sure is he did
call the cops to help her out and he
didn't do
like why she was in the closet and when
that's what I was getting at at the
beginning of this conversation is that
when the cops were first called and then
he got arrested um there was a
completely different type of assumption
narrative that was forming around him on
that and it wasn't as bad as we all
thought so it's just it is crazy to
think that oh wow he called the cops to
help her out and it led to all of this
[__] you know uh it's it's it's a six
and now how they're taking advantage of
it like Mon it's like Disney is like you
screwed us over with the whole King
situation and our other movie that's
coming out now we're going to milk your
your trial it's it's real corporations
for you mate ugly as hell man so ugly
corporations will pick you up get all
the money they can out of you and then
completely drop you now he was asked if
he's gonna thinks he's going to work
again he said he hopes so it's God's
plan that he does um and he thinks that
it's God's timing I hope that other
people think that as well well so he
says I do I pray I do work again it's
God's plan and God's timing I think I do
so yeah and that was in regards to
whether he he got asked if he deserves a
second chance as well and that's you
know that's up to the studios that's up
to the audiences as well I just think
constantly you know invoking God and the
Civil Rights movements and Keda Scott
King that that's kind of yeah he's an
actor he's not he's not them that's the
part of it like dude you're not Martin
Luther King like you're a great actor I
get it and I understand the what I I
there's a degree where I understand the
importance of what you're talking about
in terms of representation of your
people but then at the same time like
you're you're not Martin Luther King
that you're not doing this act and and
there has to be some kinde of
self-awareness in what you are saying
you know and at least convey that
self-awareness yeah during the pandemic
one of my uncles he constantly invoked
World War II any time he had a chance to
bring up World War II you didn't it
didn't matter it's just anything you'd
say oh we're in lockdown and be like H
it's just like World War it's 2 like
look Uncle you you're like 50 years old
mate you weren't even alive when that
happened and I actually reached out to
one of my friends who was American who
lives over here and I was like you know
in America do do people constantly
invoke World War II and bring that in
conversation because you guys were you
guys fought in it as well and they're
like n it's purely just a British thing
yeah during the pandemic any chance a
politician or someone got to bring at
World War II they'd be bloody bringing
them up um and that's kind of what I
sort of feel like with Jonathan Maes and
you know ketta Scott King and stuff and
Martin Luther King it's kind of I'm just
calling back to a time that people feel
very emotionally attached to and yeah
I'm trying to kind of play on people's
sympathies we should ask the audience
though man does the audience here do our
listeners think that Jonathan major
deserves a second chance in Hollywood
now later down the road I gotta ask yeah
I mean let's not be like let's be honest
the guy is really talented and you know
talent in these situations can often
beat a lot of things and there are
several actors and musicians who've done
terrible things like Mark Walberg had a
really like if you look up what happened
with him his case um Josh Brolin's
another example and there are these
Redemption stories um but I think the
first place that stems from is taking
accountability and actually apologizing
and saying what he did wrong which this
interview to me didn't necessarily come
across that way now they are doing an
extended version of it so you know they
could drop a segment in that where
completely changes the narrative but off
these clips they've released yeah I'm
not sure but obviously let us know Below
guys and uh Disney are having an
absolutely brilliant week in terms of PR
Greg as the Star Wars Ray movie uh I
don't know if you've been on the
internet this week guys but dear mate
there's been just nonstop back and both
about it um so director of the ray movie
shamin o choid she came out and said I'm
very thrilled about the project because
I feel what we're about to create is
something very special we're in 2024 now
and it's about time that we had a woman
come forward to shape a story and a
galaxy far far
away
what how dare she so yeah well Greg I
just thought it was pretty crazy that um
I think Disney have kind kind of almost
painted themsel into a corner with the
way they Market stuff at the moment
which is where every single thing has to
be the first time that's happened and it
doesn't really matter how minuscule it
is now she never mentioned Direct in the
whole comment but people have obviously
attributed that to her meaning that
she's directing a film and because
obviously we've had Bryce Dallas Howard
did a lot of the Mandalorian episodes
Deborah Chow in terms of shaping the
Star Wars Universe Greg and being a
woman I don't know if you've uh heard of
this Hollywood Executive before but
there's actually a very famous executive
attached to Star Wars called Kathleen
Kennedy Greg I don't know if you've
uh Kathleen
kedy that's the name I haven't heard in
a very long time I feel like I there's
some tumor in my brain that I've just
that has formed out of suppression from
not wanting to deal with people about
yeah Kathleen Kennedy that's
familiar as soon as I saw that I put out
a tweet saying I can already tell what
the discourse around the next Ray movie
is going to around the ray movie is
going to be for the next two years and
I'm already exhausted I'm ready for it
yeah The Floodgate Unleashed there's
been hundreds hundreds and hundreds of
videos on it um lots of comments on it
now let's be honest Greg Star Wars fans
are sensitive now when I say that word
sensitive yeah there is a negative
connotation
there's a negative connotation around it
and I don't mean it in a bad way right I
think it can be good to be sensitive I
think sensitivity for Star Wars that
comes from a place of love and being a
fan that's seen what this franchise has
gone through and I think I speak to
everyone when I say I just want this
franchise handled with respect and I I
don't feel like it should be handed over
to someone who's going to you know be
like anger people on purpose person
being annoying and obviously there was a
clip that surfaced where she said she
likes making men feel uncomfortable now
to be fair that came from eight years
ago and it was um in in context it was
talking about a documentary about
certain things that were being carried
out in Pakistan where men were attacking
women and stuff so I feel like we should
just disregard those comments Greg and
kind of draw a line in the sand under it
because cancel culture in general the
people who stand out against that are
like look this thing happened five years
ago happened 10 years ago just leave it
mate just leave it so I think in regards
to that we should do that however glad I
have to say man I'm glad you clarified
that I am glad because like even even
this morning when I was looking up stuff
about it I I thought those comments were
in relation to the Star Wars movie
initially and and then it someone else
pointed that out to me and some random
comment yeah and I was like oh my God
but everyone who's talking about this is
making it sound like she just said this
[__] about this movie and and uh yeah
and like it's a completely different
thing she's associated with you know
well that's the problem with the
Internet is that everything on the
internet's forever Rachel zler is a
great example of that because when she
said that stuff about Snow White that
was like November last year or something
no not even November last year November
2022 nobody cared Greg and then it got
brought up again and it just kind of
these clips can be played in certain
context um yeah personally I don't know
if I was a billion dollar Corporation
that's looking to bring the fan base
together a fan base that I actually
looked up and it's 60% men 40% women I
don't know right if I was the head of a
billion dollar Corporation trying to
make familyfriendly stuff if I would
hire someone who who is going to cause
controversy personally you know I was
thinking about the other day I think
John favro is like literally the perfect
person to hire in almost every situation
he was such a g for Disney because he
doesn't come out and say controversial
things he doesn't come out and piss
people off he makes bangers as well
talking Iron Man won The Lion King made
over a billion dollars who was behind
the Mandalorian Greg bloody John farro
John farro is your man he's
underappreciated makes billion dollar
movies all the time um he never comes
out and says stuff like this so not not
just being a man and not just being a
white dude I'm just talking from the way
he carries himself in a professional
manner now I don't Star Wars fans again
they are going to jump on these sort of
things um but I just feel like Hollywood
in general are just hitting a point
where they're so obsessed with race and
gender that it's almost exhausting to
just not if you're not obsessed with
that stuff and they are obsessed with it
and it just it's it becomes the talking
point over the actual products and for
people who aren't just wanting an
entertaining time it's you just see
these two sides arguing back and forth
and it's like I can't put up with two
years of this Greg I just can't do it I
know it's not difficult for me there's a
lot of people going through struggles
right now but it's just it's exhausting
to report on I mean on I feel like on
social media gender especially uh is a
big topic of conversation Real World um
struggles that go on race and gender and
so you know like and Disney
is known to play Kate to like
Progressive pandering that's the
freaking weird part to me
because the I I have no issue at all
like with a woman directing Star Wars or
any of that and I'm like that's awesome
that's like let's see what she does
awesome Bryce dallis Howard brought us
some of the best Mando episodes we've
ever had I was excited for Patty Jenkins
Rogue Squadron movie or whatever the
hell I was excited for that and and uh I
I think that the issue that Disney's in
and this is kind of odd that this
statement will be released off the heels
of Bob Iger talking about you know not
wanting to be so much about um me
leading with messaging uh and and just
make the movies entertaining and then
this movie gets announced and this is
like what happens uh right here where
that does become like the there is there
it does become the focus of conversation
and right now Star Wars
especially uh I think out of them all
out of any of the franchises uh there's
been a lot of just that discussion of
you know with the panderers coming out
just shining more of a light on it and
being such a big topic of conversation
in the zist that first off here's the
weird part to me when a lot of the times
we hear about like the messaging and
pandering and that doesn't even seem
like that's usually when we see the
final product that that is most the
runtime you know like that that it's
taking up all of it it's still be there
a little bit but it's not everything in
the way how we you know uh we we might
be initially led to believe a lot of
times things it's all everyone [__]
talks about for two years Greg yeah it
so then it it feels more magnified even
if it's not even there in a macro sense
when you're watching the movie you know
or the show and then when you say
something like this then it
automatically puts the audience members
who are exposed to this kind of
conversation in the lens of watching it
with the perspective of awareness that
oh there's going to be like women
messaging here and you might even read
more into things than you might you
might not have read into it prior if you
didn't hear [__] like this beforehand
you know and it it's not I don't feel
like it was the smartest move to do that
like I I think that there is is
something cool about like a woman
finally getting to direct a Star Wars
movie I I think that's awesome that we
because women have been involved in Star
Wars uh you know as characters behind
the scenes there you know a lot of
people coming out being like he with
like shaping Empire Strikes Back I
forget New Hope well New Hope Lucas
pretty much saved A New Hope in the
editing room she was the one who
basically shap I think people are
getting annoyed about the word shape
it's like it's good for a woman to
finally shape the Star Wars Universe now
shaping can be behind the camera like
Marsha Lucas editing it you know
Kathleen Kennedy um whether you agree or
disagree with her choices but shaping it
can also be in front of the camera as
well Princess Leia is a big female
character probably one of the like the
big female characters when you think
about it you know Natalie Portman's had
a a big career that was built off the
back of Star Wars um there's there's
lots of characters that you can point to
just the word shape I think shape is
what I think people really got caught up
on yeah and and we can get pedantic
about certain things and you got to like
treat these things with the mo the
utmost Sensitivity I I think when with
statements you release or or things you
say because things get blown so out of
proportion and like you I'm already uh
vexed by The Vortex of just darkness
that is it's already happening over over
over like a this statement and a
statement from years ago that I yeah
from from the videos I've seen or been
or the conversations I've see erupting
they're lumping them together so much to
the point where they I I I I don't I
didn't realize until this morning that
that that what she said about making men
upset was because when I first heard I'm
like man why would you [__] do that
right now like that's what I first
thought and I didn't realize that that
was an AEL clip you know and people are
just going to pull that [__] I I I'm I
am I am tired of it I'm I'm already
like I do think it is fair that people
look at your past work and comments
maybe when deciding stuff but to be fair
what she was talking about was I don't
really think once you like I I looked
into it today and there was literally a
woman with like who had serious acid
burns on her face because someone had
thrown acid in her face that was part of
the documentary and it was kind of like
oh this is what she was reporting on and
what the right things she was pointing
out so it's not necessarily I think
everyone can agree that that's a very
bad thing to do so that's what she was
talking about um I think in general
though what I'm kind of fed up with is
sort of Corporations and creatives
giving themselves a pat on the back
because you know they're not as sexist
as they were six months ago and they're
hiring people and that they could have
easily hired down the line and now they
like oh look how Progressive and great
we are and it's like well no you you
didn't give these opportunities in the
past and now you're only doing it
because you think that you can make
money from it I personally don't think
that moves like this ever do make money
I don't think that there's a large part
of the audience that will now go see the
ray movie who weren't going to go and
see it because there's a woman directing
it um and I think if this is what's
getting pushed it almost makes me lose
confidence in the actual story because
if that was what was good then you'd be
talking about that um so yeah I think
just it was sort of a almost a tonee
statement because the meaning behind it
was that basically women have been
overlooked in Star Wars but by saying
that you're now the first person to
shape Star Wars you're overlooking all
the women that have shaped Star Wars and
yeah it was H it's met with a a lot of
backlash um I think reair is a really
good way to kind of make a Mass Appeal
show um and it's not because there's a
big Hench white dude in it if you look
at the side characters um they've got
you know there's a woman of color who's
like his best friend who's extremely
skilled at everything kind of takes the
lead on stuff you could easily come out
and push that as being like look how
inclusive and diverse we are and they
don't they just let the Storyteller
itself you grow to love these characters
and it doesn't become a big talking
point and they just keep a part the plot
because they don't want to make the
audience feel like they're [__]
they don't want to come out and be like
oh you guys are bloody troublemakers but
we're here to show you either way
because six months ago we wouldn't have
do this but uh We've hired this person
now and we're really Progressive and
we're going to look down on you um Rosco
in season one and richer that's another
you know highly competent woman she good
at
stuff yeah it's just kind of that's more
the way I think they should do it and I
feel like when they come out with these
talking points it's sort of you just
know what the narrative is going to be
and what the conversation's going to be
and it just kind of drains the life out
of it because I want to be excited for a
Star Wars film but I just think there's
so much division within the fan base at
the moment and it is caused by just
people arguing back and forth about
stupid meaningless stuff that often
doesn't even end up in the film exactly
yeah it's uh yeah it's it's just it's
just exhausting Greg people are probably
exhausting for us talking about it but
yeah yeah and women have a hard enough
time as it is man like Jesus Christ to
be
fair I think like there's yeah
you could I mean both sexes you know
they've got the benef the pros and cons
to be sex on both sides um but yeah it's
kind of like not this again more this
I'm sick of it Greg dis I don't I just
don't know what Disney are doing because
they hiring people who are openly going
to do talking points that are going to
annoy people but they're giving them the
budgets and projects that should be Mass
Appeal when you look at like those
original Star Wars films and the
allegories that like George there was
that great sit down interview that you
know with like George Lucas and James
Cameron where George Lucas was you know
even emphasizing more so of the the the
allegories he was drawing with real life
war and I think that often gets
overlooked even though when the movie
came out it made might have been more a
little more apparent but that doesn't
seem like it was the main topic of
conversation and there's something about
this that the movies don't the movies
and shows don't do this but it almost
feels like that with some of the
messaging they do or that it feels like
direct messaging to the point where
they're almost turning to the camera and
saying it to you as opposed to telling
some type of allegorical tale and I
think we could always get on board with
an allegorical tale and I think even in
terms of PR there's a time and a place
depending on what the movie is or show
is we're talking about
representation of a sex or race or your
gender whatever uh will behoove the film
will will be beneficial for it and
there's also a time to realize like
maybe we shouldn't be doing it for this
particular one right now because we know
it's pre and post yeah I think once the
movie releases you kind of go back and
analyze it and be like what do you mean
aliens was actually a Vietnam War
metaphor what you mean Starship Troopers
had all this political stuff in it I
didn't to I totally missed all that um
and I think post no one cares it's it's
often in the buildup to it when it's
like Hollywood packing elves on the back
and telling you how terrible you are as
a person if you don't immediately want
to support this stuff because it does
sort of feel like they do say like if
you don't support this you are a piece
of [__] basically yeah um and it's a
weird marketing tactic but Disney don't
seem to have learned the lesson and they
seem to be going ahead with it and just
continuing and yeah but anyway Greg what
have you been drinking this week to get
your energy up oh this G fuel man my
gosh gfuel if you guys use the promo
code in the description box you get
yourself 20% off select tubs it has been
extremely helpful I think uh you have
you might have seen it happen just in
this video alone where I was a little
tired and now I am more energetic uh
thanks so much thanks to this we film
this at a time where it is the um worst
time for my mentality Monday morning
that is usually my least sharp time so
I'm usually drinking a g-fuel here so
the times where I'm like I'm most
natural best I feel like was when we
film on like a Saturday or whatever but
on a Monday I'm G to need my g- fuel
plain and simple we got marathons like
Echo to get through gonna need my g-
fuel and everyone who comes on real
rejects they all drink g- fuel now I
have converted it is my new religion and
I really stand by as a big helpful tool
ABS I I full-heartedly mean it I I I I
drink them every single day I drink your
geu I drink them all the time one the
old school references these days man
love it and if you guys want to see how
much you love it too that link is in the
description you're going to get a
discount helps out the channel what more
do you want guys you get we're giving
you discounts on stuff that's great so
yeah fantastic job there Greg I love
that gfuel gives you the power to
naturally integrate advertisements for
for gfuel brilliant now Golden Globes
Greg is going to be our last topic of
the night because it's a big one it's a
big one to go through did you watch it I
watched enough of it where I can
participate in the conversation I'll
tell you that much brilliant especially
as a half Filipino who mainly identifies
with his Filipino site because they all
stand out here Joe Koy was a big part of
my night last night I'll tell you that
much man yeah well I've got some good
news for you Greg he's went he's
trending all over Twitter might not be
for the best reason
but yeah he's put you guys on the map
you
guys yeah feel proud of it pride en
jooy so yeah best film drama winner was
Bloody Oppenheimer and I tell you what
Christopher Nolan came out he gave his
speech he dedicated it to Heath Ledger
um he also talked about how when he was
he said the last time he was on that
stage was picking up Heath Ledger Golden
Globe for the dark night um after he
died and he said he looked over in the
crowd and there was Robert Downey Jr
looking back at him and just giving him
a little little wink to say like good on
you mate or we're here for you to
support you and he said and obviously
Downey Junior's beat was a massive part
of Oppenheimer as well and it was just a
nice a really nice moment I love
Oppenheimer I think it's a fantastic
film I think the guy's you know he's
made so many seminal movies I'm so glad
to see him win this you know the Golden
Globes is very much the the runup to the
Oscars I would say it's kind of you know
where where you sort of get the feeling
about who's going to win what and most
of the time you know I'd say 90% of the
time the award winners are the same I me
yeah I hope a guy wins the osuke
deserves that as well in my opinion um
so yeah I I think Oppenheimer is
the perfect marriage for audiences to to
get excited about and for the film nuts
who actually give a [__] about this
stuff like I I care more to just read
who won then watch the ceremony I think
the ceremonies are usually pretty boring
yeah I think they're pretty boring I
might look up like certain acceptance
speeches um and I look for like some
like the monologue but there there's a
lot I just don't watch um most of it's
chopped up now on Twitter so all the
highlights you basically get to see the
next day anyway exactly the best stuff
you can watch because you know they do
these uh the Oscars and Golden Gloves
they've been trying to incorporate stuff
because they know their viewers ship's
been dying and and Es and the pandemic
didn't help them out at all so they've
been trying to do some [__] to make
things more interesting to appeal with
like Justice League winning audience
award or something I don't know and and
now they have like
cinematic and yeah they have these these
types of um box office Juggernaut appeal
Awards to try to you know appease people
who don't normally watch this [__]
because they're not part of the
prestigious category whatever right and
Oppenheimer though it's um
historical epic biopic you know and but
it but it's also Christopher Nolan so
you also get like Grand scale and it's a
billion doll hit it's it is the film
that I feel like Awards season has been
like thank you we needed this where we
can get mainstream audiences interested
in one of these because Normal normally
like these the films that are winning
the awards are becoming like the the
jugg and ruts are are often um you know
the the prestigious more Niche type of
films that ciles are more into but not
like huge mainstream audiences and this
is the the film where you're like oh we
can appease this is the one where we
could appease everyone we got Robert
Downey Jr here man he's Iron Man people
like Iron Man and he's great in it the
part I'm seeing on social media that's
surprising me granted I have not seen
every film in the supporting actor
category but suddenly I'm seeing like
conversations of oh I'm surprised Robert
dowy Jr won and I when that movie came
out I felt like everyone was saying he
deserves an Oscar nomination for it but
now that he won people are going why why
him you know I mean it's usually what
what happens right someone wins and
there's people arguing about why this
other person should have won and that's
the weird part to me of the award get
into as well all right sweet then let's
do but yeah Oppenheimer so full award
had it w um best picture best director
for Christopher Nolan best actor for
Killian Murphy best um yeah best
supporting actor for Robert Downey Jr uh
best original score as well and yeah I
think that was so yeah it won obviously
that score is a banger as well Greg I
tell you what I put that I put that on
me headphones sometimes and just listen
to it what a score so the best film
musical or comedy the winner was poor
things I've not seen it but it's quite a
controversial one because some of the
topics in it I've just mainly seen the
outrage around ni Greg I've not seen it
though but basically they put a baby's
brain into a woman's body and then have
her do woman womanly things with men and
people are kicking off about that and
saying it's disgraceful I see why it's
controversial but I mean it's ridiculous
it's a ridiculous plot yeah it's
Frankenstein remake isn't it and best
actress was Lily Gladstone for killers
of the flower Moon fantastic yeah I
think she deserved that lead actress
right not supporting uh yeah best lead
actress that one um and then Best
Actress musical of Comedy why are they
breaking it into like best actress and
then Best Actress musical or comedy but
that was Emma Stone for poor things so
it sounds like it's really sweeping the
board there best actor musical of Comedy
was Paul gamari H who did get spotted in
In-N-Out burger after just sitting in
his tuxedo having an In-N-Out Burger he
was in and- out of there quick have you
ever had an In-N-Out Burger Greg I've
never had one of those oh my God Paul a
couple years ago I gave up meat the only
thing that will tempt me to going back
to getting meat is when I sniff an
In-N-Out
drive-thru whenever they open up an
In-N-Out in the what are you doing
through the
drive-thru no it's like I might just be
you don't understand man man this you
have not passed it in and out you could
just smell it like the burgers when
you're if you're just in traffic in LA
and you're in the street is right there
next to you or like when you just trust
me sometimes I'm like I want to go in
and just like a grilled cheese sandwich
just so I can get some of the phermones
of them Burger but no they're delicious
and whenever they open up a new one in a
different state in America uh it's
always on the news because people wait
in line for like six hours it's absurd
yeah it's worth it I've seen those CU
mate they're not you might as well just
go to like a festar mitchellan
restaurant and just pay the extra bit if
you're going to waste 12 hours in a
drive-thru car got a lot of Inn outs out
here yeah they're
delicious so yeah not had that um so
best supporting actress deine Joy Randol
for the holdovers not seen
that best screenplay anatomy of a fall
seen that go yeah best original song
What Was I made for from Barbie by Billy
ish so yeah not heard that probably have
heard it it's just uh in the backgound
of the barie yeah yeah don't remember it
best animated film I saw people kicking
off about this so the winner was the boy
in the Heron Elemental was in the lineup
the Super Mario Brothers movie suzumi
wish and Spider-Man across the
spiderverse which I feel was the big
upset of the night from what I might
follow people who just love comic book
movies Greg but I tell those people
posting videos of the Ben who edits the
Mr Sunday movies his channel he posted a
video of him filming his reaction to it
and he was just about to jump up and
celebrate and then H yeah cut to it and
it was it was a boy in the Heron and he
just look so deflated that was one of
the big upsets of the night I haven't
seen it Greg I don't think be like we
really run a movie podcast yet do
we anything you just ran through the
Gambit you're head nope haven't seen it
haven't seen it and and I I I think that
people often will get upset for their
film not winning but we have to remember
whoever that guy was when parasite won
over Joker and how pissed off he was
that we ought to not get upset unless
we've actually seen the thing that won
if we're mad at what won just you know
before you go there with your
emotions feel like maybe maybe I should
watch this before I decide yeah this did
not de
to be the winner I've had my upset
parasite's great as well parasite oh I
think parasite is a better movie than
Joker in every regard honestly I think
it's a great movie yeah and it's an
original film as well which obviously
wins it a lot of think and I mean Joker
did get accolades as well um but
something like do you remember when the
artist won that'll always be the film it
was a black and white like silent film
that they made in I don't know what year
it was but I always remember that and
thinking what the hell is this Craig
they've just voted this in because it's
just doing loads of weird stuff with it
they've they've made this win but it's
not I'll never watch this I don't think
anyone who's watched it I'll ever watch
it again and that was kind of the point
where I think they were like oh maybe we
should start doing things that are
actually people enjoy yeah and so that
takes us into the Cinematic and box
office achievement which as we know
Barbie won H in the lineup for that was
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 John
Wick chapter 4 Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one I don't really I
think that was a box office achievement
I think that lost money yeah um but yeah
that was in there I I enjoyed it
Oppenheimer was next I mean it was
pretty much between Barby and
Oppenheimer wasn't it and I feel not to
get on my conspiracy theory hack Greg
but I think sometimes these award
choices it's uh they'll sometimes just
choose certain ones to win over others
because they just think oh we'll have to
give this one an award because it's
going to look bad if it doesn't if it
comes we don't get it doesn't get any
awards you know what I mean yeah um so
that's why they created this this
specific award it's the reason they
created it yeah he had Spider-Man across
the spiderverse the Super Mario Brothers
movie I've just realized Greg I was
thinking last night Taylor Swift's there
just to be in the audience and sit and
watch along nope she was actually
nominated for an award and it was for
the Cinematic and box office achievement
so the last nominee in that category was
Taylor Swift with the era tour what
exactly is the Cinematic box office
achievement it wouldn't you just go by
what made more money if you're if that
is what the box office achievement
is the Cinematic achievement of
a what the qualifiers for this category
it was number one most viewed movie on
Tuesday the 17th of May in 2023 at 8:
a.m. just look at and go what made more
mosed bar Barbie more people watch
Barbie there that's the winner right
there that's it's not a
flash W The Flash won um the SN cup when
the flash won the Oscar fan chair moment
and look I love Zak's Justice League but
I was thinking what the [__] is an Oscar
fan chair moment what does that even
mean what is an Oscar fan chair moment
and I'll always I'll Ryan tell you Ryan
was he was so annoyed by it he was
Furious about it and I'll text him all
the time saying don't forget that the
flash one the best Oscar cheer moment um
even though it was a streaming movie
just in your house that no one went to
the cinema to see so you can't really
judge the cheers but don't forget it won
um so yeah great moment that was but
yeah the Cinematic in box office
achievement it's just one of those
Awards it's kind of like uh is there
anything I think they sat down and were
like look mate we we're probably going
to give all the awards to Oppenheimer
but Bobby's been really successful this
year can we invent a category where we
can give an award to Barbie like got
bloody I've got a great idea it's the
Cinematic and box office Achievement
Award so that's it and next one best
standup comedian on television Ricky
jaes won for armagedon um Ricky Jas is
also famously hosted the Golden Globes I
think even he was taking shots at that
guy and saying like oh maybe we should
do it next
year I would love to have been there for
Joe Coy's reaction when Ricky Jes won
yeah devastated that guy's never going
to work again probably what happens when
you go after Taylor Swift mate you
scumbag H best TV series drama was
succession best TV series musical or
comedy I love how there's like just
loads of musical or comedies it's like
it's they've got their own category it's
like you can't be considered the best
drama you can't be considered for the
best movie if you're a musical or comedy
it's nice they made this category for I
love and comedy are lumped into what
like these award shows make no sense
like I I don't get why why are Musical
and comedy linked together like they're
the same thing like there's every other
genre belongs here but Musical and
comedy belong here as its own separate
thing and a lot of the times the
comedies are not even like real comedies
that they're nominating comedies Greg
when you hear the winner the music I'm
right the winner was the bear in the
best musical or comedy it's not a
musical I wouldn't say it's a comedy
either I would I wouldn't really say
it's a comedy i' say it's just like it's
sort of almost like a not a docu drama
but they the way they shoot it it's kind
of very real life and kind of um it's
like the Wicker man the Wicker man was
shot in a way that they wanted you to
believe that it was kind of had a touch
of reality in it yeah and it's sort of
like that where it has uh it's not a mus
I wouldn't say it's a comedy not sitting
there laughing the whole time through
they have the their funny moments like
the the episode where they have the the
Christmas and they get all like jam Le
Curtis in and stuff and all the cameos
but wouldn't say it's a full-blown
comedy Greg um so best actress in a TV
series was Sarah snoo for succession
best actor in a TV series drama a best
actor in a TVC sorry bloody H can't talk
best actor in a TVC best actor in a TV
series drama Kieran
so he's beat he's beat his brother muli
there
ped mclunky MCL yeah he beat Pedro as
well for The Last of Us best actress in
a TV series musical or comedy was a IO
Ed for the bear yeah great she was great
in that but I don't know again I don't
know if it's a musical or a comedy that
best actor in a TV series musical or
comedy Jeremy Allen White the bear so
the bear seems to be picking up
everything for the the TV stuff have you
seen it Greg it's good I haven't but
everyone tells like I I hear it can be
like a stressful experience in a good
way like like a stress in a good way and
uh it's because everyone's singing every
two seconds because it's a big
musical they're all singing over the top
of each
other this musical puts me on the edge
of my seat um yeah I I I've only heard
like the complete opposite opinion I
hear there's a lot of people from the
bear in the Echo
series okay yeah I didn't notice
them so yeah best best actor in a
limited series Anthology series or TV
movie was Stephen y with beef sweet best
supporting actress in television was
Elizabeth de Becky for the crown um she
was only in half the SE I mean she
played Diana to be fair she did a great
job with Diana but I feel like if she
was going to win it she should have won
it for last year don't know if she WN it
last year but she didn't really do that
much this season I don't think it she it
sort of the first part of it revolved
around the buildup to Diana's death and
then the four episodes after that were
kind oh it was I think it was six
episodes after that kind of a young
William coming up in the world and
meeting Kate Middleton and stuff but
yeah she was she was good as Diana I
suppose and best supporting actor was
Matthew mcfaden in succession and that
is the awards so yeah I mean we didn't
really see much of them Greg to be fair
so I don't really know how we can have
an informed opinion on it but lots of
people on the Internet seem to Give
opinions about movies that aren't even
released yet and talk about how crap and
terrible they could be so I'm gonna say
that that list is all
wrong wrong I want to talk about Joe
Koy I let me do it go for it let me do
it with my panoy pride seeping into this
podcast right
now uh once people were watching our
podcast and they were saying like oh I'm
sick of these two white guys talking
about stuff they don't understand and I
was like I don't even know what Grace
Greg
[Laughter]
is I I get out here in La I get a lot of
different I've had Armenian people come
up to me like when we're in a
conversation usually at like the sauna
or the steam room at the chip like
you're they'll ask if I'm Armenian they
think I'm Armenian get you know Mexican
I get I've got an Iraqi Persian I get a
lot I'm Italian and Filipino my Italian
side's all in New York I live in LA my
whole Filipino side is in Phil is in uh
gundale California out here and uh I
mainly see that so anyway well that's
why I hired you Greg they were like we
need some diversity on this podcast I
was like I need a guy who ticks all the
boxes every single possible race and I'm
the I'm this weird aall where I'm around
my Italian I don't look like Italian
that I don't really look like the
Italian one I'm like oh you definitely
got that Asian in you and then I'm
around the Asian side and and I'm like I
don't really behave like my Asian family
just like weird mix been wh ified in
some way and uh
the but I was with my family a couple
weeks ago and they mentioned Joe Koy was
a hosting the Golden Globes and and like
a lot of Filipino households yeah you
know was like joeoy he's like my mom
loves joeoy because of the kind of
Comedy he does and I've always thought
he was like and now you're pretending to
be Italian again yeah now I'm like no pH
I forget that I forget that that's in
me whatever I've always been more
Italian been more forget about it um so
I uh I I sent to them I family like I
don't know what it is about Joe core
this is exactly what I said a couple
weeks ago I was like I don't know what
it is about this guy but he's got like
future cancelled Vibes uh that he gives
off I've always had that opinion about
him and I didn't think it would actually
be for his comedy I've always thought
that someone's just gonna come out and
say some [__] about him and my I didn't
watch any of the um the social media
reactions prior to seeing the the the
monologue I just decided to like look it
up because I heard the Golden Gloves
were going on I was going to go see a
best friend for dinner and I was like
I'll watch this and I could not believe
just how embarrassing it was let alone
like everything with like Ricky jves uh
of how like great Ricky jves is and how
he's become such a staple of knowing how
to roast he's he's got that ability to
roast everyone in the room and still
went over the crowd you know and the
second Joe Koy started
apologizing and throwing writers under I
get being nervous I understand that like
there's parts of it where I can sure
sympathize for it but this level of
like insecurity that just started
shining through in the monologue and
then putting down writers like in the
middle of after what we just experienced
with the writer strike and just not
taking talking about like we're talking
about like accountability and stuff and
like not taking ownership over this and
then at times like taking Jabs at the
crowd there were a few jokes that I
thought worked like the saltburn joke I
thought really landed well and like the
daero about uh being 80 years old and
you know having a kid like I thought
that joke landed well uh but I I I felt
like that feeling of secondhand
embarrassment when when watching it like
this is really not a good monologue and
like other comedians have bombed it's
not the end all be all of things but
this is a lot of he's not like the
biggest name for a lot a lot of people
have not even even heard of joeoy like
he's big at the same time he's not like
Ricky D's big you know and so I'd never
heard of him exactly like a lot of
people have not heard of this guy
and even though I think I speak for all
people Greg I think I'm I'm pretty much
the Filipino people know Jo oh no John
campy has talked about well you're all
canceled now cancel you're you're
ruining the good name man um so yeah we
was Jolly Be now and uh he's um that was
that was a really embarrassing
embarrassing monologue I I got to say
normally I'm the guy who's like trying
to give some benefit of the doubt I I do
feel like I will be like well you know
guys it's a lot of pressure whatever but
I thought his handling of it was all the
things that I've ever felt like this is
why I get future cancel Vibes this like
insecurity back some narcissism you know
it's it was it was uncomfortable to
actually uh to witness and everything
thing that people were clipping out you
know when they cut to people have mainly
been highlighting the Taylor Swift
reaction yeah yeah that's the main one I
saw rightfully so because that was
really bad like that w wow she was did
not all she did was like take if like
that that phrase if if looks could kill
like my God she look she not look happy
about it but you know they they would
have wide shots to other reactions you'd
see like Harrison Ford um and other
actors just not either no emoting or the
slight Shake of the head like they
couldn't believe what they were
listening to the one that I did kind of
like that I thought was funny that did
not seem like was going over well with
anyone like when he did the killers of
the flower Moon jokes uh about like how
you guys took the premise of the movie
like there were that joke actually did
make me laugh at but man when they cut
to Martin scorsi I don't know who was
next to him but when they cut to Martin
scors he just not even like a hint of a
smirk that was really rough it was
really really looked like someone had
just told them they're going home to
watch Marvel movies what was the joke
about the flowers of the killer moon I
missed it uh of the flower Moon sorry I
don't know I don't know I'm gonna Butch
a joke that already did not go over well
um um is something about like yeah I
didn't realize it was the joke was a
simple premise of oh oh you white people
stole everything they took everything
they even took the premise of the movie
and and and and I thought that that was
actually a funny play on how like a lot
of the convers maybe this wasn't his
intent but at least how I took it how a
lot of the conversation was how they
wished it was more uh from the
perspective of the indigenous people in
it and not uh not just the white
people's perspective so I thought it was
actually kind of a funny joke and that
did not seem to go over well at all
though with Martin
scorsi yeah it was embarrassing
it's a shame because the Golden Globes
can often give you like mainstream
eyeballs and you know if it goes down
well I think it open the doors a lot for
Ricky chice obviously um I know he's
obviously he was an established name at
the time but they just kind of took him
to I mean I've watched so many of the
clips from that speech that he did where
he was just ripping into all the people
there yeah H and yeah just you know
people bomb on stage to be fair lots of
comedians do but yeah he just I don't
think he handled it well throwing his
wrers into the bus and especially after
a writer strike yeah that was bad so
yeah probably not see him back next year
unfortunately no man I think who's
hosting the Oscars this
year is there a host is Jimmy Kimmel
know did they get away did they get rid
of the hosts after um Kevin
Hart oh yeah yeah Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Kim
he's your safe bet man time
hosting yeah four times he's done it he
just knows what he's just he probably
just gets something he just reads off
whatever he say see you guys later I've
done this times his Show's under AB his
Show's under Disney the Jimmy Kimmel
show so it's all it's all
synergistic it it's all promotion and I
think my personal I would love to see
will Ferell and did you see will Ferell
and Kristen wigs um Golden Globe yes
like that was like such subtle I know
about three hours of that Greg no no but
three hours of that but they've had them
do presents they've they've done
presentations before and I've like seen
the clips before that I think they're
really hilar they are hilarious together
on the and this is a very different bit
than what they've done prior and I
actually think they would do an
excellent job hosting I would love to
see them do
it let's get them on let's get them on
Greg get whoever anyone but Joe Coy
terrible that was awful yeah so how how
do your family feel about him now I
haven't talked to them we can't look
each other in the eyes other and just
kind of heads down
yeah let's go to church now oh well I
hope you guys uh have enjoyed going
through we've touched on some very
sensitive subjects and I always feel
it's difficult to waigh on these
situations especially as a lot of them
are ongoing you know that full interview
with Jonathan Maes might air and he
might come out looking amazing and yeah
what a strange thing it just felt very
vought very vought vought and paid for
you know what I mean Greg it was all
kind of a PR stunt if them maybe testing
public opinion to see if they could
maybe get maybe get the guy back in some
way or another because I mean they fired
them really quickly but uh like James
gun's a perfect example of them getting
rid of someone and then being like
public opinion's changed a bit can you
come back and do this job for us so yeah
we we'll see what happens with that but
obviously let us know your thoughts on
all the stories I know there's only
really been three ones with the Golden
Globes um the ray movie and and Jonathan
majes but we'd love to hear thoughts on
them you guys keep the podcast alive
because I tell you the second that these
views aren't good I'm I'm on the phone
at Greg and I'm saying look it's not me
well it's it's not me it's you and we're
going we're going to part ways and the
podcast's over on the phone you're gonna
have Mt send me a text message I know
you do be like sorry after the whole Joe
Ki thing I can't be associated with you
anymore but it's not me it's like well
you told me you were big four of them so
you cancelled as well canceled by
association I'll do it I'll deal with
it imagine hit the thumbs up cancels all
Filipinos mother eward yeah well that
might be what happens Greg I mean people
on the internet they're looking for a
reason to hate and we're hopefully
cutting through that noise to give you a
reason to feel like not positive but
just sort of hu I don't hate this stuff
but I'm not excited about it either I
think I might go watch it back to the
future break break down that 45 minute
long one that Paul's just made that's
all he cares about making anymore but
yeah echo's coming next week Greg which
looking forward to the discourse around
that well when we're talking about it
yeah wa I thought it comes out
tomorrow yeah we're releasing the
podcast though just before the Embargo
lifts and then we'll be talking about it
next week so yeah this gonna that's what
you me fun
conversation they were like I was like
wait a minute did I get my release dates
i f whole week I I need to shoot all
this Echo [__] I don't even know Disney
release dates anymore cuz I'll watch one
trailer when I'm doing editing bits and
it'll say like the echo stuff said
January 10th and then I clicked on the
next trailer to get clips from that and
it said January 9th and I'm like what
the what the hell's going on because
they keep doing that thing where they'll
swap the release times around like what
if was back to UK release times and I
was like oh thank God for that nice
relaxing Ling I get to not getting up in
the middle of the night to talk about l
um but yeah Echo seems to be back to
that time but we'll see how it goes I
think the conversation about it going to
be very interesting Greg so make sure
you guys are back next week with your
opinions ready to type them furiously
away and engage with the videos and
watch the adverts as well and we
appreciate you guys as always enjoy the
rest of your week I've been Paul I've
been
Greg Tata